哇 台灣股市今天又大幅反彈了
三天而已
反彈快3000點
可是反彈見優三
很多人想要知道
今天台灣股市
三天大漲快3000點
則告訴我們的隱憂是什麼
另外一個很明顯的隱憂了
記憶體大產
中國大陸的記憶體大產
發布一個大的利空警報
這空襲警報是真來假的
則怎麼解讀
為什麼我要特別解讀這個空襲警報
因為看起來
有可能是真的
怎麼辦
第三個
7月台灣股市
还有机会五万二吗
韩国股市今天在崩了
淘安股市为什么一支独秀
所有的独家的标题
独家的介绍
我今天一次讲得清清楚楚
我要告诉你为什么
我们可以告诉你独家这一切
而且股票为什么还那么飙
这告诉大家
台股天天千点行情完全没极限
7月第一天台股马上栽送大家千点大礼
投资长早就告诉大家
上周五第一点44454点
很难再跌破了
果然本周连三天都大涨
而更没有极限的是投资涨的标股
真的已经碰到无法无天了
环球晶今天一开盘就涨停锁死
还有投资涨的盖牌股
我爱美元这档股票也一样
股价跳空开高
马上就上涨停
你还在思考这波究竟是真反弹还是假反弹时
投资涨的会员们已经赚到财富翻倍了
你手上还没有标股吗
想知道投資賬接下來會買進哪些股票嗎
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
國者榮投資賬
投資賬好
莉莉 各位朋友大家好
大家好
今天台灣股市都漲很多了
可是有隱憂啦
來看一下
你看一下這個股市
台灣股市今天漲了又快1000點
有沒有
893點
你看一下
各位看官你看一下
韓國股市今天跌2.04%
因为三星跟海力士都大跌特跌
一个跌3%
一个跌5%
算很多了啦
台积电一天给你跌个100多块
你也受不了啊
是不是
所以我要告诉大家
在这边韩国股市跌
最主要就记忆体问题
等下我一次讲清楚
所以台湾股市三天
谈了快3000点
2800多点
那其实在这边而已
我觉得稍微休息一下
也没什么不好
来来来来看一下
可是我不是看空空
七月行情我是觉得不错
你看現在真的很猛
哲哲 你不是說不太可能V轉
可是我也說這邊低點不會破啊 是不是
可是我說拉回是買點啊
是
我還是看法一樣 我覺得不會一下子就順進去
V轉我定義是這樣子
V轉一轉一轉 我覺得不太可能
但不太可能不是說 那我就不要做多
或我要做空
No way
可是我告訴大家為什麼
因為韓國股市 你看一下韓國股市位階
我們看一下韓國股市位階
我快速跟大家講
韓國股市的位階
來來來 看一看一看
你看在哪邊
還在禮拜五的低點
有沒有看到 禮拜五不是下去嗎
對不對
禮拜五一個長黑K嗎
是
是韓國股市 禮拜五黑K
台灣股市
已經全部收付這個黑K了
還一副要創新高
這台灣股市
日本股市
這個黑K還沒收付
有沒有看到
所以台灣股市
台灣股市是有本錢一支獨秀
為什麼
因為偉大有錢的各位
你們很有錢你知道嗎
賞物很有錢
衝衝衝向前衝
你看一下 我們看一下
融資昨天又增加了174億
什麼沒有
我昨天看那個
今天看好像假三
是假三零代銷是不是
他說現在買房子很辛苦
是
不是賣房子很辛苦
沒有人要買房子什麼
都拿去買投資股票
賺比較快
也是啊
現在房子
那這個已經變惡性循環了
因為房子現在買了
除非你是乾性需求
你要 OK
可是通常只買1000的
不會想買第二間
以前買第二間會投資
對
現在沒有這個投資的需求
有自助需求
但沒有投資需求
為什麼
因為投資完以後又不會賺錢
還要被課一堆稅
所以資金都跑到台灣股市
所以台灣最強大的就是
現在買股票的資金
非常的雄厚
非常的豐富
豐沛
我是跟大家講的
好
所以來
可是我覺得
多少會影響一點點
所以大丈夫
如果明天有點拉回
你要看兩件事
第一個拉回的時候
你要找跌比較多的
你要找疊比較多的
頭子沒有
上次有人嗆我
後來不就封鎖了嗎
因為我覺得人到一個年紀
人到40歲以後
有時候有些東西
看不順眼的就趕快走
你看不順眼我
拜拜
我看不順眼你
那時候我說
這時候你又不敢講我愛美元了
我為什麼要跟你講
你有猜對對不對
你有猜對你敢不敢買
你敢不敢抱現在
那些抱怨的人都不會抱到現在
他們猜對了覺得自己很厲害
但不會抱現在
今天我愛美元
就怎麼樣
就暫停啦
你知道嗎
而且這檔股票
我剛才文章就告訴大家
所以你要記得加我的LINE好不好
記得加我的LINE
我基本上臉書沒再什麼用的好不好
臉書每次都亂封鎖人家
我也受不了他好不好
那也沒問題啦
我告訴大家
這LINE也是
我是全台灣唯一官方認證的
應該說不是
第一批啦
第一批
記得
這個點一樣
有藍色盾牌打勾
藍色盾牌打勾了
就是LINE認證
再點照片
有寫已認證有沒有看到
有沒有看到
好有人數你
欸你按已認證
你看所有分析室裡面
我們人數最多喔
二十幾萬喔
LINE喔
然後YouTube是唯一百萬喔
欸你不看我你看誰
你不看我你看誰
一百多萬的粉絲你不看我看誰
哪個分析室有的像那麼多
沒有啦好不好
就你不看我我看誰好不好
這跟大家講
那我剛才講那我愛美元
這跟
大家就先開牌就知道啦
這跟環球晶有關係啊
所以我每天也在解他
對不對
程庄製程這一塊
我每天在解他
所以你要去看看
你要怎樣分析師
我今天開牌股票都暫停
我愛美元
台灣No.1
台灣No.1是少數
一直漲我不想先開牌
因為買的人不多
我想說算了
你們大概也知道什麼股票
算了算了
對你們很好
下次這股票
今天我有心得
我買大送小的專案
什麼叫買大送小
大家一起跟你講
一起跟你講
好不好
我說買大送小的專案
就是一個大型的全資股
一個比較高價股
送一個比較低價股
你兩個都可以賺
或者你買低價股也可以
都一樣飆
這樣好不好
台灣股市反彈見優三
好不好
這個慢慢先跟大家講這些東西
股票啦
先慢慢講
先講
先我們
先講我們的部分績效
再開始再解一下
韓國的記憶體
跟中國的記憶體
發生什麼事情
來
大陸
先講一下績效
你看看
年發科
有沒有看到
賺了大概130幾%
一部分是賣快150%
一部分賣124%
國具
沒想到還能再展一倍
厲害
所以這行情
只要要趕爆
就是贏家贏很多
管達沒什麼賺
這是剛才出掉
還沒出掉
有沒有看到
藍雅科95%
然後就贏他囉
樊軒跟金財都算5幾%喔
你自己看喔
樊軒跟金財你自己看喔
金財是要拉起來了
是不是
對
樊軒
這金財
6196樊軒
創新高了
等一下喔
6196樊軒有沒有看到
又創新高
今天股價創新高有沒有看到
少數這種行情還能創新高的
所以哲哲選的股票都是低低起的
之前漲很慢的
都是這樣子喔
然後低低起的啦
你看你這件事情
你看智元也是低基期啊
因為以前有400多元啊
現在200多元怎麼會高
是不是
你看以前有400多元
你看以前前年的時候有459元
有沒有看到
所以我買200多元也是一樣啊
金彩跟樊薛
我也是因為什麼
因為萬潤啊
以前100多塊被人家罵過
你知道還跌到好像100多元以下
現在就1000元了
你知道嗎
前陣子不是1000元嗎
那這種就漲很多的股票
你要選低基期的股票
台灣股市的確有小小泡沫
的確漲很多
所以就是因為這樣子
你越要選低基期的股票
你懂我來說什麼嗎
懂
越要去選低基期的股票
我們不去四歐瓦
或不去馬後炮
這是跟大家講
來 我們慢慢來講這些東西
所以我們來看一下
先來看我們最好的一個績效股票
這績效表來是普通位元
我們百萬粉絲
數以萬計 數以千計的位元朋友們
請你見證
我這普通位元的績效
簡訊表達並有造假
我們用一個相對比較低的成本來算
我們不要全部假起來不得了啊
這效果恐怖啊
好不好
我們相對來比較低來去算
這跟大家講
環球金一個暫停
兩個暫停
三個暫停
四個暫停
五個暫停
八個暫停
是不是每一次
而且最恐怖的是
我都知道它回答幾%
你們自己去算一下
環球金也是
環球金今天直接暫停啊
先臭屁黃環球金再講
韓國的記憶體
中國的記憶體 台灣的記憶體
再揭開來跟環球晶有關的
撥害美元好不好
好吧 應該已經部分人知道了
來 很恐怖的是來
這邊剛好回答25%
你們自己去算出25%
不多不少大概就25%左右
這樣就回答
這樣子
你不覺得好像有人在算計他嗎
回答25%
這邊回答25%啦
你不覺得很扯嗎
真的耶
都25%啦
是
我跟我說25%可以買了
你們都不理我
好像三次都25%耶
到這邊有到25%嗎
快要快要
欸也是25%耶
不會吧
好像這也是25%耶
是啊
對 六百多元
因為它這裡也快25%喔
好像三次都25%
我記得這邊25啊
這邊25%
三次送分題給你 你都不理我
三次送分題給你 都是殺到傑聽版
這麼好的股票 當時你說
嘖嘖 搖瓷金母 誰誰賣
我說他強 任他強
不管人家 有時候一死紅一死紅
之前搖瓷金母很厲害 是不是
那現在也有一些網紅 很厲害 是不是
有喊被動元件 喊整流二極體
大家都一陣一陣
可是從頭到尾一直厲害
不好意思 姐姐
因為我是你們高度監督下的分析師
沒錯
這跟大家講
好不好
這個都可以作證的啦
我看一下玩意我們
績效表更新
怀仲金100%
是啊 你可不可以不要那麼混
寫錯了
其實怀仲金100%
有沒有看到
你看到怀仲金
我真的耐得住性質
每一次就對了
你這邊放大
每一次
每一次串心高
我都没走掉
拉回
我在进场
串心高没走掉
拉回
我又找一个点位
这次没有
这次太快了
太快了
因为它不像三次这样
直接跌停所死
你知道吗
是
就赚100%
你看
环球金730元
跌停那时候买
用力买
越定越高
你看70元叫你买进
有门到
还告诉你要全存
叫你挂跌停买进
有门到
新位也买的
已經持有懷孫金的勞會員
還加碼
還加碼730來漲到1145
賺了40% 50%
懷孫金今天最高已經賺100%
我沒走
我覺得懷孫金有機會2000
只值現在1000元
你跟我講2000
你不要再算
不要再算
好不好
當然我不會說一定
我們是合法分析
其實記得
沒有一定這回事
好不好
過去一定也不代表未來一定
OK嗎
這個先跟大家講
來
所以這個環球金有沒有
恭喜
選美小姐
6488環球金股價一開盤就暫停連兩天攻上暫停暫停暫停我們多次擺進最高已經大賺100%黃球晶也很好笑黃球晶也很好笑跌的時候跌很慘
暫停那你都買不到
你不覺得這張股票很特別嗎
真的
財富翻倍我持育卡拿
手上持股獲利虛報
我真的不敢想像
黃球晶解禁後
他股價會多強你知道嗎
你知道嗎
現在是還沒解禁就這樣子
解禁後到底多強你知道嗎
我真的是觉得很夸张
好不好
来来看一下玩友的反应
应该很多人玩友金赚不少吧
来来来
看这个看这个
来
现在来
还没按赞的给他按赞
鸿海怎么收跌
来
今天大展员工少一个了
会员到勤
用美元支付会费绰绰有余
谢谢大家
来
來 紅海
紅海不用緊張啦
紅海爛骨
你們講紅海爛骨
他聽了會難過
來
有沒有看到
沒有造假
看很多人說沒有造假
有沒有看到
台股創新高
記憶體全部失憶
失憶
只剩失憶
跟回憶
會員環球金
算400萬
有沒有看到
會員講的
算400萬
來來來
會員
有些是鴻海的
鴻海基本上如果是我會員
我不會叫你去中壓
你到底是我會員嗎
不是會員應該不用緊張
只能聊一下鴻海等一下來聊
頭轉真的很強謝謝大家
頭轉今天FSD不能買斷
你覺得我那時候想
到底要買FSD還是不買
就是特斯拉的支架
就是要買還是訂閱
那不重要
我真的沒有時間去管這些東西
那幾萬塊的東西
我還是要幫你們賺幾千萬幾億的
我自己的事情我沒有在乎
我如果在乎我一定千方萬想
把我的1.74億美債給出掉
然後偷偷換台灣50
問題是我沒做這件事
我跟你講我這麼紅
而且我也想過我這麼紅
如果偷偷做這件事
說不定哪天醫院想出去
我就想說算了
不要做這種事
雖然可以多賺很多錢
有時候我們要在乎那些小錢
來
這跟大家講
投資產真的強
其實大家
納科怎麼辦
納科我們成本很低
我比較氣的是群年
我不會怕藍雅科
你知道嗎
因為群年根本沒動
我比較氣的是群年
你知道嗎
納科離我成本太遠了
可是藍雅科再疊下去
我會考慮
就是因為成本高低的差別
你知道嗎
我要告訴大家
我比較不擔心鴻海
我鴻海來玩你講好不好
來
那當然有些粉絲
粉絲啊
如果你不是我會員的
你自己要去想
為什麼我強的你沒買到
那如果是會員不用緊張
因為如果是會員不會去
我們紅海不會去重壓
不會說all in
這一檔股票
所以你要去想想看
是我會員不是我會員差別
好不好
我買大送小的專案
買大送小就是我買像這種
大的
比較大的全值股的
比較貴的
你不一定想買
你也想買
一起買
大的什麼
我剛才講的環球金
是
我在送小的
我愛美元資產股票
而且是有關係的
市值比較小
價格比較小
買大送小
而且還199方案
送標股還送199
還有199
這麼划算
這跟大家講
所以你自己來電洽訊好不好
或加我LINE視訊我
加我LINE視訊我好不好
加我LINE視訊我
OK嗎
來 我們來看一下
那個他剛才不小心
畫面切到你身上你知道嗎
所以你不能偷懶你知道嗎
沒有
一夜七星你
不能再插BT之類的
沒有啦開玩笑
頭長
你說
今天我覺得您時時刻刻都在想的會員
對
所以有一首歌很適合
有一首歌是不是
好我看一下
這首歌他們沒給我耶
沒給歌詞耶
那個我跟你講
那個四遙故意整你啦
一一故意整你
找不到歌詞耶
他們沒給你歌詞
我們看一下
等我一下
正在練他們在混
他們真的在混
現在給我歌詞
四爺挖洞給你跳
他不想你唱歌
是不是
四爺不讓你唱歌
真的嗎
真的沒給你歌詞啊
現在找到了啦
曾貝慈
一個人想著一個人
他是不是最近什麼
浪解期
是不是得第一名
真的嗎
應該是吧
我常看很多新聞
我不知道
我什麼歷史故事啊
我都看了
像我最近在迷一個
什麼日本的一個
搞笑
主持人兼那個
兼那個
兼那個大導演
北野舞啊
我看他所有人生故事
你聽過對不對
好像有聽過
反正就是這樣
就是我會看他的歷史故事啊
為什麼成功失敗啊
歷史
我什麼都看了
我什麼新聞都看了
我很喜歡研究人性
因為股市就人性的綜合啊
好不好
所以AI很難去預測股市
來啦
想一個人想著一個人
投資產想著會員們
是不是
好
是
那就唱吧
3 2 1
這一波行情狂標
三五圈都瘋狂
太古連盆三天
千點天天上漲
環球進場聽 中美景也噴
長滿滿的紅盤
買到松小川岸 買到落的算販
現在就跟隨著著著
七月行 請你別再錯過
李李 這好聽是好聽
那小韓他發生什麼錯誤 你跟我講
嗯...
你不知道
我先講了
你講
我先把
你先把某個標語講出來
菜鳥就是菜鳥
妹妹要認真啦
我的問題
你的問題啦
好啦 沒關係啦
NG也是一種美啦
不然怎麼只能在想
來啦
所以節奏
你幫我節奏打亂了
沒關係
來 我們來看一下
來
所以居然都把它先開牌了
可能不知道先開什麼股票
剛才不是環球金暫停嗎
我愛美元暫停嘛
對不對
我愛美元是什麼股票
剛才已經先開牌了
不知道你記憶力如何
來啦
我愛美元不是中美金嗎
為什麼
四亞那個都沒有寫清楚
好累喔
都要提醒你們
提醒一下
哈囉
來
看著我
我們在跟他們講話
要專心
好不好
你也要專心
四亞要專心
金金也要專心
都寫得不清楚
我愛美元是什麼意思
就是我中愛美元
我中愛美金不是嗎
我中愛美金不是中美金嗎
就這麼簡單
來來
中美金
那中美金是什麼
中美金就是環球性的母親
公司啊
是不是
啊市值差很多啊
一個是善櫃第五大
一個善櫃第十七大
中美金比較小啦
因為中美金比較便宜啦
也有差啦
好不好
恭喜我愛美元
五四八三中美金
連兩天跳空噴散展平
我們買進到現在
最高已經獲利13%
我持續靠他
30%獲利虛報
乾噴而已啦
那可是又賺錢啦
就賺錢了啦
因為創新高了
你看喔
中美金是不是
你看中美金這個價格多少錢
今天才198元
是不是買大送小
是
買1000元的送你200元
買1000元送你200元的
買比較大全值股
比較大市值的
送你比較小市值的
買大送小
所以我現在也覺得
也準備好股票了
也準備好股票
我現在一檔股票
這個名字我不能再跟大家講
因為你們都猜得出來
我也可以猜
那你們猜
完全猜不出來的
但我覺得這樣有點不好玩
所以我今天覺得
在還沒有暗示你之前
我先買
你趕快來找我先買
好不好我先買
OK嗎
這5480中美金
你自己看
我自己有人說這真的你又不講了
我不講
我沒有不講啊
你知道嗎
跟大家講
出事了出事了
不會啦不會啦
我現在涵氧變得很好
就跟大家講
以前脾氣比較差
我以為是誰好的
今天LINE簡訊有開牌
LINE簡訊有開牌
跟節目有開牌不太一樣
觀眾群不一定百分之百一樣
沒有關係啦
這個都小事
來
唱得很好聽好不好
昨天剛買環球金就現賺
暫聽真的是拉回就買
拉回就買啊
昨天買來不及啊
哲哲哲大氣那個
寫對字好不好
寫錯兩次就封鎖
這樣也能唱太厲害了
好好聽
這歌
這歌是滿難唱的
比較平
其實越平的歌越難唱
這樣講沒錯
是不是 我現在也有
也有音樂素養了好不好
有
沒關係
乘風波浪七的第一名
對不對 沒錯
猜對了齁
來
來 這個南亞科要法縮會了會變法會
我覺得就是在利空
就是所有的股價上漲
都是一直不斷利空質疑他
所以沒什麼不好
沒什麼不好
OK
來 這跟大家講
來來來
來看一下
所以這個中美金
你看看股價是不是噴出去了
是
你要去想一件事
這下去的時候很多人抱怨
你怎麼不想的是買點
就像現在有些股票
紅海大家覺得不行
其實紅海你說不行
但你怎麼不想是買點呢
你怎麼會說什麼嘛
還有
紅海你說不行
一樣群演你也覺得不行
你怎麼不想是買點呢
納科那時候也拉回很慘啊
你懂我意思嗎
327是精彩
那時候也拉回很慘啊
不是吧
你們想的是抱怨
如果你們想都是抱怨
而想的不是機會
第一個
你不論賺不賺錢都不開心
因為沒賺錢的時候你很不開心
賺到錢的你可能已經走掉了
你會嫌賺的不夠多
所以內心的涵養
內心的素質的瓶頸很重要
你相信我只是大風大浪
我就是關心一個美債
少賺個兩億
我就是都跟你講了喔
現在只有美債我受傷的世界喔
如果你跟我講說美債我讓你賠錢
我看你絕對不是我粉絲
為什麼
因為早就讓你0050讓你賺回來了
莉莉我說的沒錯吧
沒錯
我早就讓你賺回來了
我昨天看了這
這幾年的績下好像是50幾%耶
還是60幾%
他們喔
你看72元到現在112元
又70%了
關從3月到現在
是不是大概快60%
所以我要講呢
你每在怎麼虧
也不可能虧了什麼60%
你知道嗎
你虧個10%就很多了
全部都賺回來了
我要告訴大家的是喔
我真的是中
為什麼
這次我會成功
不好意思喔
這樣講話的臭屁
就是我都是把每一次的挑戰
每一次的回答當作機會
你只要知道最慘是什麼
問你紅海會下市嗎
紅海現在最大問題最慘是
他減少你的機會成本
你聽懂我意思嗎
什麼叫減少你的機會成本
因為現在你錢卡到紅海很麻煩
人家買環球金賺兩天
你紅海沒有辦法
你聽懂嗎
這畢竟是你不能all in
你all in代表你不是我會耶
那你為什麼省小錢花大錢
那既然知道鴻海最危險是這樣子
那至少不是下市
你就不要緊張
不要緊張
然後機會都留給準備好人
這做什麼事都是很認真
然後從每一次挑戰中抓到機會
我們舉例來看一有沒有
今天切畫面
不是切側面了
先正面再切側面
先正面再側面
你看這個昨天小韓不練他
昨天看是不是身材很短有沒有
他說他昨天給我一堆藉口
我就直接念他
你不要給我藉口
這麼小的事情不要來煩我
你看這畫面切是不是好看多了
這個也要盯
所以整個每天都在盯
好累
不要叫投資長叫投盯長好了
好不好
都要盯大家
所以說你說我們摩爾基下怎麼不會好
是啊
每天就盯就盯就盯就盯
你懂嗎
好不好
這跟大家講
跟對主流股
真的很漂亮
免費載
我覺得應該是很多的免費載充紅海
那以後有些會員買紅海
但會員買紅海
問你件事啦
來啦 假設會員啦
一個紅海啦
一個環球金啦
一個中美金啦
你覺得他會生氣嗎
不會我再看一次一個紅海啦這最大霉啦我就300元買了好不好一個中美金啦
一個環球金啦
真的長聽
環球金這樣子喔
是從這邊開始買喔
你覺得會生氣嗎
不會
他只是問我說
到底紅海要不要換而已
不會生氣
所以如果你真的是免費宅
那你什麼股票不滿
你剛好買到一個紅海
那代表的是你就是應該加入會員
你選的股票
我已經一堆標股了
買的股票大多數都是能賺錢的
你剛好選到那一檔不會賺錢的
你自己選到那檔不會賺錢
你就是要加入行列
你選人就反指標嘛
像巴黎就是以反指標為名啊
巴黎當反指標也賺了不少錢啊
是
我看他的暗戰人數
我看他應該關斗內相關的
那些就是因為他當那個網紅的
我認為它一個月至少有七八十萬
我不跟你誇張張
我去應該有七
至少有五十萬
我跟你說真的
官司這些就是收入
為什麼扯這些
好啦 我說說
你當繁殖標也可以賺錢
可是說重點是最怕的就是不上不下
是
你知道最怕就不上不下
你知道嗎
最怕就不上不下
很現實的
不上不下
你還會一直努力一下
所以如果你真的你今天一選
我選股票我就是都選錯了
更要參加我行列
你懂不懂
好不好
OK
投丁掌
對啊
丁是那個
丁大家的丁
好不好
殘
你說我幾歲了
他有這種身材
我說我六日都在重訓跑步
我跟大家講
好不好
我已經
實質的已經超過40
我當分析師20年了
不好意思
20年了
謝謝
實質的年輕就考上分析師了
這跟大家講
大概做股票已經做超過30年了
來
免費仔是流量的
沒關係
我說免費仔會怎麼樣啊
那個
100多萬粉絲裡面
有120萬
125萬都是免費仔
不會怎麼樣啦
我不會嗆他們啦
免費仔不會怎麼樣
我覺得你們只要是粉絲
有時候看到我跟我打招呼
我就笑笑這樣就好了
打招呼就好
有時候因為
姐姐有時候比較喜歡一個人實關
不好意思
越紅會發現為什麼有些藝人
會有人群恐懼症
以前沒有人知道嗎
你知道那種感覺是
就是有時候
譬如說走在這邊
譬如說跟家人跟媽媽走在一起
他在看我
他說你不要多想
就在看我啊
真的也在看我
你知道嗎
就覺得每個人在看你
沒有辦法 投資長太紅了
就紅啦
是
久了就是這樣子
沒關係啦 這扯遠了
來
資源能加碼嘛
我覺得資源線圖也不錯
好不好
這跟大家講
你說聯好光華 謝謝
有在運動好不好
這是Iran沒有
我是Eran
我比較外向
Eran是外向沒錯吧對不對
是嗎
對
好
女生
你看女生都會研究這東西
問那個啊
Eran啊
Iran啊
什麼
MBTI
對對
MBTI啊
是不是
好
MBTI啊
新柱啊
BMI啊
都問女生就好
體重也問女生就好
OK好
好來
跟大家講
為什麼衣服左邊扣戴透東西
這個是領巾好不好
拜託
這只是政治標記好不好
我帶動這個風潮的
你不要這樣子
這真的有歐包的包袱
有歐包包袱啊
來好
看你直播兩年的粉絲想請教
分
那個投資產分析記憶體的後續發展
這個比較重要來
來我跟大家講啦
這個
我跟大家講一件事好不好
大陸的記憶體市井對不對
它就是說
它說報價已經觸停
有沒有看到
已經歷史高位
恐怕出現相當幅度的回落
你知道什麼站場
我問你一件事情
為什麼他要發出警告
來 我們看一下
這一波跌最慘是什麼
台達電
台達電為什麼從2700
一下子跌到1900
跌三成嗎
2500啊 跌到1790
跌38 你知道什麼嗎
因為它一路從300多元
漲到2000元有沒有看到
它漲得多是不是隨便一回漲就回漲很多
對
它漲不多
當然不會回漲那麼兇啊
所以為什麼
5483中美金我敢買
我請問你呢
你看今天漲上去很多
它有漲很多嗎
我們看周先生知道
它趴在地上耶
是不是
最近才噴出去沒錯吧
對
你看日記人知道啊
之前都沒有漲很多啊
所以為什麼我敢買中美金
我敢買次元
我敢買300多元的國具
懂嗎 300多元的國具
因為它下跌的幅度不會很大
好 現在他已經講了
它下跌幅度很大
因為漲很多嘛
就像台達電漲很多就回彈很多
所以這是廢話 也是實話
可是是觸頂的
可是股價這樣子
當它觸頂的時候
的確有可能最好賺的走掉了
所以我等一下重新評估基底
這是利空
我會跟你講 這是利空
可好只要在
呃
記憶體那個 我要說實話
我南亞科的成本都很低
群聯不一定
可是群聯的好處就是
它也沒什麼跌
是
可是這行業喔
就是這樣好玩
就是說
我覺得南亞科影響比較大
好不好
為什麼就是No Flash這一塊啊
不是說Net Flash啊
當然全部都有差啦
你知道嗎
你看
你看喔
造詣創新認為
粒基型記憶體市場與主流
第一論
跟內的市場不同
有沒有看到
這跟大家講
來來來
他是low flash的競爭有沒有看到
有沒有
他主題產品是low flash好不好
跟DDR4跟LPD
DDR4-6-4-X
他的對手是什麼
這個LPD
LP
LPXXX
太長了不念了
就DDR4X啦
這是藍亞科有沒有看到
三NOFresh
萬宏跟華盤店
你懂不懂
所以是這三個產商才是怎麼樣
受益量比較大
他有說過
這個NOFresh跟NetFresh這些相關的
可能稍微不太同
好不好
稍微不太同
最主要
反正重點最主要受害者是
萬宏 華盤店 藍亞科
所有這三檔股票
你要稍微注意一下下
只有
只是成本很高
成本很低
所以我不用擔心
我知道現在還賺80%嘛
沒錯嗎
你們看一下喔
這會員都可以作證喔
因為納爾科上去我就沒在加碼
長太快了
有長太快不是好事你知道嗎
因為我沒時間加碼
就像我台灣No.1一樣
沒有時間加碼
是
所以我不是先開牌
不是因為他沒長零啊
他長零喔
應該已經有人都
他大部分都猜出來
納爾科我還賺95%喔
所以這個是利空喔
這是利空喔
我跟你講這是利空喔
好不好
我哲哲很老實
所以哪一天AI泡沫
我利空會跟你講
該走要走
你不要擔心
走了以後賺大錢
你怎麼假設我們拉到五六萬對不對
回膽再回膽一萬點很恐怖對不對
不好意思五萬點再進去
你再賺一波
你相信我
股市本來就會回膽
只是誰能把握住而已
聽懂嗎
誰能把握住
這個記憶體這個是利空
當然很多人說利多利空
可是股價
其實股價是看一個趨勢
什麼叫趨勢
當然這個股價
這個報價
甚至有時候誇張點
比如說我航運股報價
報價散展的幅度已經下滑了
關於散假的幅度
比如說我本來是
本來是漲30% 30% 30% 30%
我變漲20%的時候
有些比較敏感就股價下去了
是
漲價的幅度
從漲30% 40%變成漲20%
漲價幅度變少
不要等到報價下跌
等到報價下跌已經來不及了
所以現在
至少有可能散展的幅度已經差不多了
你懂嗎
你跟我說什麼嗎
懂
那股價散展幅度
不是 報價散展幅度差不多
那有可能股價到底
至少這一個如果情況
如果沒有在一個更大的利多去刺激它
比如更大的需求或怎麼樣的話
有可能股價是到底
南亞科的股價是到底
聽懂這句話
有可能南亞科的股價是到底
所以你看大摩要反指標
不要出報告好不好
大摩
你們可不可以
多介紹一些底部的股票
好啦好啦
單分一四都很辛苦啦
不要覺得我在酸他們 好不好
不會啦 不會啦
往好處想 我也幫他們打廣告啊
就很多玩意有酸我 我也覺得你幫我打廣告
你不要說 哲哲啊
什麼故意害你啊 什麼造假
這我不能接受 我沒做的事情
你要我承認我是沒辦法的 你知道嗎
好不好 酸我 哲哲啊 怎麼樣啊
相信哲哲 真是要存哲 我聽得開心
相信哲哲什麼 財富對哲
我聽得笑笑 我也不會生氣
你都說這我就不會生氣
這沒什麼好生氣的
是不是
野餘的話我不會生氣
可是不能那個毀謗
沒有的事實你不能亂講
OK嗎
不然我都指著
EQ還算OK啦
氣也氣不完
來
所以大母我真的不要再出報告
不要出那種
不要出到股票牆的時候看報告
高色你說HBM看漲44%
怎麼看
是跟大家講
來來來
價格要再漲
HBM有可能再漲
這我不敢確定的
所以一個利多一個利空
但是中國會有這個利空
我覺得我等要寧願相信一個利空
要注意一下好不好
這是第一個
第二個成熟
這個所以說
所以說你要去看一下
拿雅科
我們用技術線圖來看
所以這個時候就要看技術線圖
跌下去的時候一定要看技術線圖
因為跌破的重要支撐
今天這個價格底部價格不能跌破
底部價格跌破是月線的WAVE值
底部價格在哪邊 413元 有看到
有
月線的地方是413元
再注意一下 413.93元 413元
加上記錄線圖
所以配合基本面 籌碼面 技術面
一起看你才知道
大門的報告啊 這些籌碼面啊
外資的看法啊
然後國際產生的看法
最後看技術線
知道嗎
記錄線你也要看
雖然記錄線其實落後指標
但落後啦 已經下去你才說不行啦
使指但它不會到非常弱
OK嗎
這告訴大家
所以台灣股市為什麼反彈
台灣股市為什麼反彈
建這優山好不好
那我們最後十分鐘
我們再休息一下好不好
只是喝個水
因為等一下要跟你講說成熟製程怎麼看
好 問有沒有人做HBM
台灣人當然沒有
台灣沒有人做HBM
因為技術打不了
休息一下我跟你講一些
成熟製程的
還有就是成熟製程講到很多啦
中美金啊
環球金啊
世界先進啊
成熟自成的報價擅長
為什麼世界經濟今天這麼弱
還有很多標股 紅海怎麼看
紅海剛才已經講過了 有時間再講
這些股票怎麼看 休息一下 忙回來
剛才很多人問一下
剛才很多人問說中美金有沒有機會到300元
就我們今天揭開股票
我愛美元是中美金
美金
有沒有機會到中愛美金
有沒有機會到300元
現在股間200元
我就說中美金會拉到198元200元
中美金會拉是環球金
我都說來的問題想一件事喔
環球金如果可以從1100漲到2000元
漲得快一倍嘛
是
那中美金漲50%很正常吧
所以當然有機會啊
答案出來
我告訴你邏輯啊
你懂嗎
欸 環球金跟中美金應該亦不亦虛啊
環球金可以漲到200元
你關事這些權益法任列的一些禁例
多少啊 那是很龐大的
基本上不用算了啦
算給你聽你肯定可以看不懂
直接我們研究部都知道答案了
所以你他到
環球金到2000元
我覺得中美金到300元的機率是99%
前提是要到2000元
那到2000元其實高不高
我覺得有機率啊
你這樣懂嗎
我講是環球金環球金只要到2000元中美金應該也會到300元而且機率很高來 先跟大家講我媽媽是哲哲老師的貼本
謝謝你喔
好不好 多孝順媽媽
知不知道
每次我都要準時收看
連我都要跟著看
台積電加油
我最近收購中年輕
我就要帶媽媽去買東西了
我買最貴的東西
你應該知道啦
我跟妳討論過
我自己基本上
不會買很貴的飾品
這跟大家講
買最貴都花在媽媽身上
對啊
這跟大家講
好 來
所以大家都孝順爸媽啦
投資長為什麼莉莉不談琴呢
難道各位
因為各位不是牛啊
沒有啦
對牛談琴
開玩笑
沒有啦
那牛逼一點各位
為什麼談琴
我怎麼知道
對為什麼談琴
這個小事情啦
用AI猜者
用AI猜者的股票
有些猜得到
廢話 有些很故意要讓你們猜得到啊 好不好
還扯遠了 韓國還在殺難
夜盤蹦蹦蹦 哪個蹦蹦
我有跟你講很難V轉啊 好不好 我有講喔
我們看夜盤
跌251點
46963 便利價差了喔
明天休息 三天彈了快3000點
休息一下會怎麼樣
休息好啊 你知道上規指數有展就好了
你聽懂嗎
我剛才就跟你講了 我說很難V轉喔
可是我有說上禮拜五的低點也很難破喔
好不好
在裡面有低點難破喔
所以你也不要問我說這利空是真的假的
其實利空有可能
當然我覺得這利空是真的
沒有產生會無緣無故
講自己爛你知道嗎
你問位置家會說自己台積電很爛嗎
所以我跟你講
重點是真的爛
三星海利是也真的跌了
不是 真的爛
這個利空是真的好不好
這跟大家講
來來
我旁邊兩位同事要被我拉進會員的
謝謝大家
畫面給我
受不了的加會員的
真的受不了的 OK
TW Fit Boeing
我今天有說什麼
泰勒斯啦 講八卦
我聽說泰勒斯明年會來台灣
不是老實說
真的嗎
我這個對
跟我沒關係
你看我什麼都講
我都亂講話好不好
真的啊真的啊
來 扯遠的
才開演唱會吧
好啦 扯遠了
這個股票沒關係啦
扯的世界怎麼看
你們看陳仲智誠喔
趕快趕快
所以有時候為什麼股票
有時候名稱我都不小心講出來
我還記得有一兩天
我不小心講中美金
依依有沒有印象
好像有
有對不對
你們看我就不知道
根本不是say好的
就我很難
所以我不太喜歡說完話
因為很難喔
嘴巴有點大
很難都很難
很難守密啊
很難
除非朋友跟我講說
不能講不能講
我就記得
來 成熟製程代工報價
看展到2027年啦
Trainforce
Trainforce是很專業的研究機構啦
來 這跟大家講
AI需求與工業資金有沒有到
這個已經全面調升了
因為 我就跟你講喔
我說你去看一下
你說這個最新的製程
不需要 不需要
不需要先進製程
成熟製程也需要
有些邊緣運算也需要
就像我跟你講
你可能前面想到吧
一個iPhone手機
哇 用三奈米的
no no no no
也有很多是成熟製程要
都需要好不好
你你你
我問你一件事啊
殺雞硬要牛刀
你最新的核心的運算
你可能要最新製程
啊有些旁邊的
旁邊需要一些資源的運算呢
或邊緣運算呢
不需要欸你懂不懂
那我只要成熟製程就好啦
你聽懂嗎
現在你一堆新聞跟你講
二級期都可以漲價
二級期的漲價
成熟製程不用漲喔
最核心的不用漲喔
最多人都可以漲價
都要漲啦
所以台灣股市還有很多低基期的
到現在才剛穿歷史新高
哪種不買
這就是低機起的而已啊
以前也快兩百元啊
是不是
所以你看我都選很低的股票
資源很好
環球晶也好
環球晶以前就有這個價格過啊
你知道嗎
中美晶也好
都是
都是剛突破歷史新高
在還
歷史新高一段距離的股票
買了很安全
好不好
來
供應端
台積電三星減產
是不是跟那時候機體一樣
哇
哪邊好賺我就往哪邊走
我不要乘手自成
需有端
AI伺服器有沒有
通用型伺服器有沒有
一般的投入型式是需要它
對不對
雲端管理晶片
供應元件
FPGA
你看
這個也是用
也是用TrackGPT圈們來做的圖
你看多漂亮
8吋金月難有沒有看到
一估到90%就差很多了喔
差很多了喔
我用簡單的房子
房子來入住就好了
你知道有很多飯店
你可能住房
看起來住很多人
住房7成是虧錢的
可以到做房子到八成九成就賺翻了
就你不要差那個10%
差那個幾%的一個產能利用率會差很多
原本可能七八十%
像八十八%開始在大賺錢的
到九十%不好意思就賺翻了
這跟大家講
所以這事先先進利基電
所以利基電會比較
它有特殊製程啦
也有特殊製程
利基電也會受惠
利基電就什麼都做嘛
所以六七七利基電
我覺得 那今天為什麼跌
因為大家覺得他
覺得他的那個什麼
記憶體的比重比較高
但是久了以後發現他有神功護體
但是我覺得你要買成功製程
就買成功製程
你要買那個
記憶體買記憶體
立體電視兩個題材都有啦
他現在比較轉向
是那個記憶體這邊啦
好不好
來 我們來跟大家講
所以成功製程還會缺
那最強成功製程還會缺
請問你
我按摩托機器事件今天在怕什麼
我完全不必緊張
我告訴你
這邊210以下
你要記得我講的話
你趕快把握住
到時候噴出去
你不要說我沒錯
37是精彩
也是要噴出去的
你不要說我沒錯
明天很多股票拉回
你要買
沒有拉回
你更是要報老
要報老要報老你知道嗎
沒有要趕快追一追
你看
繁圈在剷新高
一堆股票剷新高
現在幾分了
來
黃金一根斬停
兩個斬停
三個斬停
四個斬停的黃金
5個展停 6個展停 7個展停 8個展停
跌停板我買 2次 是不是
買 2次
730 老會員也買 老會員也買
老會員又買跌停板 厲不厲害
然後 9個展停 10個展停
11個展停 12個展停
12個展停 13個展停
14個展停 你不覺得環球金的人設很刺激嗎
真的啦
我說不是展停的跌停
只是展停的次數比較多
環球金今天兩天展停大漲100%
大賺大賺 我們會員賺100%
這是普通會員績小
所以幹部員想說
哇 受不了加入會員了
是
幹部員想說加入會員賺400萬
這是會員實在的一個紀錄啊
我愛美元
真的啦 我都報很久欸
這種行情最適合我 你知道嗎
就一個波段報到
來 中美金也是一樣
我愛美元不是中愛美金嗎
就是嗎
是
美金不是中美金嗎
對
中美金不知道
這不是環球金的
環球金的那個相關公司
那時候我要暗示你耶
很多人說
哲哲你怎麼沒有解釋我愛美元
哲哲你這樣很過分
我說怎麼沒有解釋
我解釋 我那時候不是暗示你
我解釋環球金就是解釋它嗎
對不對
對
我說我有解釋它相關的股票
一樣的意思
我是不是說一樣的意思
對
今天為什麼暫停
中美
它持有一堆環球金
但是一起暫停啊
有些人說愛亂抱怨
沒關係沒關係
我們少數人而已
大部分是很愛我的
五四八三共美金
連兩天都跳空分散暫停
最高獲率13%
只要持五獲率虛報
我標13我要130
所以你不要問我說
會不會300元
我本人就想要打算
300元以上
我
我股票如果賺幾百分之百你叫我走
真的你瞧不起我
這種行情你真的瞧不起我
不要來找我好不好
如果你是要賺
如果你是要賺二三十百分之百
拜託
賺二十百分之百三十百分之百
拜託你去買0050就好了好不好
可以嗎可以
你去買0050好不好
我是說認真的
我不是在酸你
二十百分之百你就划算了
拜託你去買0050
那如果一兩百分之百你就划算了
你去定存
你一輩子都被通膜打敗
好不好
看起來有錢的越來越窮
真的是越來越窮
傻瓜在買錢發在銀行
來 講那麼久還是很多要這樣做
沒辦法
來
恭喜6196帆旋
股價一度大漲快8%
再穿率先高
我們多次買進已經大賺67%
聞到
環境界限廠啊
精彩也賺了58%
漂亮
漂亮啦
明天就算回答你也不要想太多
各位
好不好
就算回答你不要想太多
117多久
差不多要結束了
好不好
看到他們什麼問題
來
反正就很強啊
好不好
我今天買友達馬上被套住了
時間跌10%
友達跟群串就沒什麼
他是技術線型
他就沒什麼基本面
我記得我們公司好像有些分析師有買面板
你可以看他們的好不好
我沒時間講不是我的股票好不好
他們應該有買不錯
應該都買滿低的
這只是抱太樂視的料對
怎麼都抱
怎麼看收盤時間延長到三點半
不要啦
好不好我們已經很累了
不要
不會不會
我覺得有這個新聞嗎
有這個消息嗎
應該沒有吧
不會啊
兩三點半很痛苦耶
不要
我反對
因為我工作時數已經很長了
而且沒差夜盤
現在有台紙期了
沒必要了
現在已經有台紙期了
我有時候凌晨兩三點
我都還在看夜盤耶
所以已經夠了
好啦扯遠了
所以謝謝大家告訴我們
所以今天最後跟大家講來看一下
所以他最後那個維新啊
維新跟那個不用看了
今天這個維新昨天
因為昨天是那個
那個被動ETF的成分股落入
最後一天比較有買盤
好不好 跟技嘉
今天小展小跌
最後要跟大家講啊
來 精彩
賺58%有沒有知道
然後樊軒賺67%
然後最強最強是什麼
環球金中美金
一開盤就暫停
沒多久就漲停有沒有看到
沒多久漲停
這就是我們的我愛美元
環球金一開盤就漲停
我愛美元
環球金也跟他有關係
賺100%了
這在一切一切預告前面
今天就連
哇有利空的南亞科
都賺快100%
你去想看你要漲分息是吧
想清楚想明明白
來來來
今天買大送小
什麼叫買大送小
買大的什麼
環球金 1000塊環球金
那時候買啊
五四五百塊是不是
對 500塊啊
五百多塊啊
不然你怎麼現在賺100%
你看啊 你覺得500塊
哇 現在變1000塊了
再買小的
哇 從500塊賺到1000塊
你再買一個
200塊的股票
中美金
是 買大送小
1991會專案
我下一檔股票我準備好了
這一次我不給你任何提示
因為這是以會員的權益為主
想清楚 想清楚的話
歡迎來練下旬
我們買大送小
我們這個大的標股是什麼
買大
還是先買小的標股
我都想好了
0800668085
或是加5LINE私訊我
不論對我做者的一切一切
一關在前面
買大送小
三天台灣股市
漲了3000點
拉回就做多
7月仍然有機會
5萬了
我告訴大家
只是它會有一點坎坷而已
那你要把握每一次的拉回
把握買大送小
191個專案
專案及標股不等人
預祝各位能夠賺大錢
謝謝
本公司与所推介分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家